[Music]
hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and magic
dragon so if you're a human living on
the surface of the earth by now you know
that e-cigs and vapes are everywhere but
perhaps you didn't know it's billowed
into a two billion dollar a year
industry that's a lot of money to be
spent on what is literally vaporware but
all is not rosy for these tokers the FAA
recently banned vapes on a plane
starring samuel l.jackson citing the
fact that they can contain harmful
chemicals the more times you heat it
over and over and over again that
contributes to some of the carcinogens
or formaldehydes that we see in these
cigarette aerosols according to some
recent research couple that with tales
of exploding batteries child poisonings
and all kinds of other bad stuff you've
got to wonder what the hell is going on
here how much of this would a kid have
to drink in order to be harmful one sip
can potentially kill a child within 20
minutes or so well today we're diving
into the world of vaping to see if we
can find out all right so at the vape
shop in LA this is Ren Ren take me
through some of the basic equipment here
so let's start with a starter kit the
vapor production you get from this is
not too bad mid tier it's either one of
these bad boys over here this pushes
more power than that device so you have
an option of putting a rebuildable
atomizer this is the Ruby mod this is
one of the most high-end ones out there
these ones are more for the real
enthusiasts it's more for flavor chasers
they just want like the purest possible
flavor you want to make sure it's evenly
glowing on both sides they give that
even vapor production so you're like
burning off the excess the residences
the residue that has been on the coil
now we're gonna get this primed and
ready what goes into the hardware the
liquids that we have over here we have
fruity deserty
we have adult flavors - what what are
the adult flavors tobacco flavors
whiskey you don't have anything like
grandpa's fingers no keeping the classic
the flavor that you have here is a fruit
loop flavor to fruit loops
yeah
that is a fruity O'Shea breakfast cereal
if ever I smoked one so I know like a
lot of vape shops have their own
competitions what what are you guys
looking for in a cloud competition it
depends on the judges but mostly
distance intensity so I you know teach
we have blow like a really big cloud
sure my first shot by Jason I think Ren
solidly won that one so should move on
to some tricks this is rich he's a
vaping trickster we're gonna start off
with the ghost okay
[Music]
do you specialize in paranormal activity
now that opening what's next double
always hey there is person - a little
weak if you get the concept though which
is good what's next we're gonna do the
tornado go with your hands just go up in
motion thank you Sam you know what
though and then the
so after vaping all morning I want to
know what it's doing to my lungs so I'm
heading to USC's health emotion and
addiction laboratory to talk to some of
the top researchers in the field a lot
of people say you know hey this is
vaping it's not smoking right what is
the difference between vapor and smoke
you take any kind of mixture of
chemicals and you heat it up to a
temperature there's gonna be some
chemical reactions that are occurring
right and some of those chemicals are
gonna be hazardous and there is a
governmental agency I believe that that
regulates food flavorings and stuff like
that you can take a chemical that's safe
to ingest and swallow it may not be safe
tune how I think one of the issues that
Sinha raised is the substance that's
been used to create a buttery
consistency so if you get like microwave
popcorn that's caused by this chemical
diacetyl that's safe to to eat and
swallow but inhaling it's a different
story
workers in in these plants that we're
creating these bags of popcorn that have
you know the diacetyl buttery flavoring
we're developing this rare lung disease
companies are putting diacetyl in their
ejuice because you need something to
create that viscosity so we've got this
like popcorn flavor right okay that we
know when inhaled that causes this major
lung problem and yet these companies are
putting it directly into juice that is
meant to be inhaled right right
but we don't know whether if you vape it
it has the same effects it could have
very little effects and or it could have
equally severe effects so we're trying
to study that right now that kind of
raises a point this is also new that we
don't know anything about the long-term
health effects is that about right
exactly right so I'd like to talk a
little bit about what's in these various
liquids we know that nicotine is very
toxic if ingested we've got these little
bottles here they've got you know fruity
pictures on them how much of this would
it take to kill a kid it might only be
one or two milliliters now a sip of your
coffee that you take or even a child's
sip is about five milliliters so it
would just take a sip to kill a kid and
yet we don't really have childproofing
on these what why is that that is one of
the frustrating things about these
products because you can buy a lot of
things tylenol
sprin Drano and those all require
packaging that is child resistant right
and when we're getting into these like
these bigger custom rigs what's the
problem there
they're lithium-ion batteries and what's
happening is that people are maybe
overcharging them using improperly
chargers in addition they're carrying
extra ones in their pocket and if your
phones in there if your keys in there
anything that has metal on metal contact
can start a fire
so we've seen burns two legs the groin
region but also these have exploded for
lack of a better word when people have
been having it close to their face and
we've seen bad burns to the face and to
the neck region in the upper chest from
these batteries exploding so what did we
learn here today listen I used to smoke
in years later after all the chemical
dependencies have faded away I still
miss just playing with the smoke so yeah
vaping today was really fun for me but
at the same time my lungs feel
absolutely trashed they say it takes
getting used to but I'm positive my body
does not want me to get used to that so
it's possible that it could be a
healthier alternative to smoking
cigarettes but here's the scariest thing
vaping is so new that we know nothing
about the long-term health effects
maybe it'll prove to be harmless or
maybe we'll see a sudden spike in lung
cancer twenty years from now we just
don't know but if we learned one thing
that's beyond question it's that you
absolutely have to keep this stuff out
of kids reach because even a small sip
could kill one in twenty minutes flat if
you're making the choice to try vaping
you have to know what the potential
consequences could be personally I say
hold off until we know more but what do
you think are you gonna give vaping a
shot let us know in the comments below
subscribe to Wired if you haven't
already and with all that being said
there's really only one thing left to do
[Music]
[Laughter]